now um there's a fourth wave sweeping
the cont continent with countries like
austria as i've said recording record
numbers um how worried should we be
about
that surge in infections uh on the
continent
we're all looking with with grave
concern actually and trying to determine
whether there are differences in the
situation in europe um or whether it's
just a matter of time until this faces
us here i mean just briefly to be a bit
more optimistic there are some reasons
why there might be a different
trajectory delta the variant we're
dealing with now became dominant
particularly in central europe later
than it did in the uk we opened up a
little bit earlier particularly in
england and so we dealt with our delta
wave in the summer and early autumn
we're still in it of course but not
those big rises
and then the other features are around
unfortunately because we've had high
infections in the past but probably a
bit more natural immunity in the
population as an immunity post infection
particularly for younger groups who've
not been eligible for vaccines and then
the other thing is that the vaccine
rollout in europe if you look at the
population level these countries you're
talking about netherlands even more
vaccines than us austria a little bit
lower germany roughly similar
and but they deliver their second doses
earlier for many older groups they're
certainly seeing waning now and they've
also got in some
parts of the population some pockets of
hesitancy which are causing real concern
so it may not be the same
but you know it's very uncertain
uh well i want to come to the issue of
waning immunity in a second but before
we get there i mean
you know in a way there's an example uh
much closer to home for us in england
and that is where you are in scotland
where in spite of what you said about
the uh factors that might uh lead us to
be more optimistic the scottish
government has essentially been tougher
particularly in relation to
transmission risk and has taken steps to
reduce transmission risks which are not
being taken
in england um
does that worry you should
we we in england be following the
example that you have in scotland
well i think if you look across the
devolved nations actually trevor
throughout this pandemic there have been
slight differences i mean let's just
look at face coverings for example
you're right that is still required up
here as it is in northern ireland wales
in some settings that it's not in
england and if you look at the surveys
people are far more likely to report
they are wearing them here even though i
don't think compliance is 100 by any
stretch
so that's a factor we still have
stronger advice to work from home and
then of course we have a modest
certification scheme wales has just
expanded theirs on monday
i mean
we've continually had this question
about should the uk use the same
approach across all four nations my
personal view is confusing when the
guidance is different but on the other
hand the devolved nations have authority
in relation to public health and indeed
the nhs it's that it's a devolved
responsibility
and so we'll see at the moment if you
look at the ons infection survey levels
of infection in scotland are a bit lower
than they are in england we've got real
concerns about northern ireland it's
really difficult to make those direct
comparisons but of course i would prefer
that people were wearing a face covering
in public places and trying to follow
those protective behaviors to keep
themselves and others as safe as
possible
can you talk to us about about this
issue of waning immunity what's the
evidence that the
um protection offered by
double jabbing is waning uh in a
meaningful way or a way that should
affect policy
well you've got two different types of
evidence there the first one is real
world where you can look at large
epidemiological studies that just show
what the risk is of being infected of um
becoming unwell and going into hospital
depending on the duration or between
your second dose and when that event
occurs and you can see that those who
had their second doses earlier there's
more evidence of waning you also get
that from studies like react where
they're looking at a random sample of
people in the in the population who are
swapped that's that's one source of
evidence and then the second of course
is from the trials for the pfizer trial
for example where they looked at the
effectiveness of boosters they were able
to look at some of those features so
it's very clear that there is waning
it's not uniform across groups
but obviously people have more
vulnerabilities if they have underlying
health conditions or they're older and
those groups got the vaccine first in
most countries and so i think it's
pretty clear from that evidence and also
from the studies that have been done in
israel for example looking at what a
booster can do getting that protection
for example from antibodies for say
fifty percent
uh six months post second dose as it
wanes right back to over ninety percent
and that's what we're trying to achieve
here in the uk well it's um
it's evident now that everybody thinks
that the booster is important and in
fact there's some suggestion that um the
booster gives you
a better coverage i've had mine i i
guess i'm now told that i'm 93 95 96
uh protected um
is this now going to become part of our
life like the flu
jab every year that we're going to have
to have some kind of booster against
covet
i think that's scientifically uncertain
at the moment i'm not a virologist or an
immunologist but speaking to those
colleagues it's pretty clear that that
is a possibility the great thing about
the boosters trevor and i cannot
emphasize enough the importance of
people taking up that offer or going
online for people in my age group and
booking their appointment asap six
months uh second dose please please do
it it's the key for this winter and is
that it it kicks in almost within seven
days if you look at some of the studies
or or we have an immune memory that
responds again to that vaccine it's
possible like influenza as you point out
that we will have repeat delivery of
boosters in future uh particularly for
older age groups but we don't know that
yet we need to study in the in real time
the effect of these vaccine programs and
see and see what happens but you know
back to the first question you asked me
if we can really continue to deliver
boosters at scale we can continue to be
cautious in our behavior and try and
adopt those protective behaviors even if
they're not mandated everywhere
you know i'm really hoping we can
despite what chris said about the huge
pressures on the nhs get through this
winter without it being a disaster and
without us having the situation we had
last christmas
the um the health secretary rather
dismissed um my question
that uh
essentially in truth what the
government's doing even though it's not
called this is pursuing a strategy of
herd immunity of course that's become a
sort of dirty phrase but in truth that
actually what they're hoping is a
combination of induced immunity and
natural immunity will as you just just
said protect us through this winter now
he's got to say that because he's a
politician you don't uh is that in truth
what's happening here
i think if you look at children there
certainly has been a strategy just to
allow this infection to go through our
young populations that's very clear to
me um
different governments around the uk have
had different views on that and of
course we've had to follow the guidance
of experts on the jcvi but i think
you know if you look at the minutes from
that committee in terms of the decisions
that they took their huge expertise but
if you look at the minutes and if you
look at some of the narrative
particularly at uk level it certainly
has been the case that this is a mild
infection in children it's probably
better that they just get it i don't
think that's been a strategy for older
age groups um you know we're worried
about long covered uh the risks are not
zero to young people i would like 12 to
15 year olds to be able to have their
second dose i would like us to consider
what's happening in the us with vaccines
for younger children in the long term i
think to have protection through
vaccination
if it's safe and irrespective of age is
far preferable to allowing it to happen
just on mass through natural infection